hello and welcome to this video playing
demented monkey from Norway so we get a
ready by transposition and I think I'll
go here yeah I realize I he's playing
like it's the easiest thing ever instant
moves ok so how to do this usually in
those positions all right is quite happy
if we can trade with 95 for example how
he takes with the bishop ok I expected a
pawn takes of course ok so I was
thinking a 5 is the only move
essentially obviously it disagrees we
note that this is so terrible for black
[ __ ] I felt this is just helping me a
little bit that I can push the bishop
bag and have this control over D for now
let's see it so as you know I'm not a
clear thing in black I want to say black
is fairly active but actually isn't that
position is pretty awful for black
strategically speaking maybe he can put
a night to see for that sets the only
weakness my position has this week's
potency form okay so okay maybe nitro G
six song not quite understanding what's
going on I can play push up h3 here
that's an interesting way of doing
things but i also like this move
preventing any bishop a six ideas
95 is also sometimes interesting but
we'll see I mean I had a hard time to
guess any office move so you never know
what's going to happen next
okay so 96 so what's the deal here
whoopsie eight is one thing but if I do
this isn't isn't the Queen has recipes
that defense stuff yeah I mean that
cannot be bad really and I don't see how
he is not trading queens okay this way
but this isn't that a worse way actually
I can take and play the bishop now
look see several miss just around the
corner so 96 now would actually em get
me that Bishop it is not a very good
Bishop Tom not clear I can also go nite
be five but then a six ok I think I'm
going to do this this is really quite
debatable but maybe has Bishop t6 or
something like that here maybe maybe I
can take I can take on v8 it's not
terrible or anything much uh-huh that
that's probably a good move because it's
not all that clear if b 5 is so great
and it's not a big choice though I have
to do it
ok so just three on my book it's not
getting trapped is it listen I would be
extremely embarrassing but I don't think
so i can go into the seventh and
possibly have a seven so this is okay or
do six is that sorry this happen is that
the best square for it yeah let's have
an eye on boucheron itm oopsie a taboo
good seven okay so he wants to go but it
doesn't really work
to aid
maybe this one for 96 not quite sure
thought that this is quite dangerous now
with the pawn maybe he can actually play
oxy eight I mean as weird as it looks
maybe you could have done that ok so
here I can play c7 rook c8 rook takes f7
asset doing the trick I think it does
I could have just taken d5 huh that that
was a little bit easier still if I take
their and I it should it should the
check be burning check black resigns
okay I think that this setup was a
little bit questionable I mean BB takes
here it's okay yeah this is an ok
position for him I'm very certain here
now very certain is strong but I think
this should be okay I don't have any
pressure on the center i would like to
maybe do this put some pressure against
c5 but my pieces are not that active so
i probably didn't play the opening all
that well this is also ok but he
absolutely has to go a five now it says
there's no problem with this move I mean
this is not a weakness I cannot attack
it also make this move easier to play
and after this i think i'm fairly
comfortable then this night is heaven I
think a couple of questionable decision
also I mean this is not really doing all
that much you never get anywhere with
this night yeah i was thinking you
should take and and play this position
maybe a five i mean it's it's
uncomfortable for him but it shouldn't
lose or anything it's now got
interesting I really wasn't sure about
96 now because that bishop on b7 is a
really stupid piece but then swing
position it's better for y itself the
engine wants to go night f5 also making
quite some sense and this is the thing
at this
I mean I didn't I didn't miss the move
by that completely and the estimators
probably I have to go here and hmm you
know yep ok so I took it a five and this
is all all nice again I have three it's
strong I didn't see that FCF three just
rinse piece but ok ok this also seems to
seems to win the game and now look t5 is
much easier than this but it also wins
so I didn't play the opening well but
after that i'm pretty okay with what i
did here it should definitely on play
this a five more think this is good to
remember this kind of thing just stops
before and it makes my regrouping much
more difficult as the night on d 2 is so
misplaced it rather wants to be on c3
and in the game I got it to be three
which was a big difference now the night
had this fantastic d foursquare
available and yeah it was comfortable
then ok guys thanks for watching